Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and
today again I'm gonna talk about
language learning, of course, and in
particular, I want to talk about the
learning zone and the comfort zone.
Now, obviously learning a foreign
language is all about getting outside
your comfort zone because we are
typically most comfortable speaking our
own language, however, because speaking
of foreign language is something that's
desirable for many, many reasons that
I have talked about in my videos.
All the reasons why we wanna be
able to access another language
and another culture, communicate
with people in another language.
So it's a desirable thing to do,
but it is something that takes
us outside of our comfort zone.
Different people, of course, have,
um, different levels of resistance to
getting outside of their comfort zone.
So, um, and, and I'm gonna leave a link
to, uh, various or at least one, uh,
page I found on the internet, which
talks about the comfort zone and the
learning zone, and sort of suggests
that when we are in a comfort zone,
we're not learning new things...
it's not that we're stagnating,
but we're not expanding.
Once we push ourselves into the learning
zone, we're meeting new challenge.
But then as we overcome these and meet the
new stimulus and absorb it all, we grow,
we learn, and that's the learning zone.
Uh, some people even talk about the
panic zone, where we're in a zone where
things are too difficult for us and
we can't cope, and then it's panic.
So obviously in learning a
language, we want to push ourselves
outside of our comfort zone.
However, I have always found as a
strategy that it's very important to
find as many ways as possible to take
some level of comfort, some of your
comfort zone into the learning zone.
Now, what do I mean by that?
For example, I've said before, I
don't like to get too deep into
the sort of exotic, esoteric
aspects of another culture.
In other words, things that
are very unfamiliar to.
It could be the festivals that
are related to that culture.
It could be, uh, special
names they have for members of
the family, special customs.
All of those things I
will eventually learn.
But when I start into a new
language, I would rather start with
situations that are familiar to me.
You know, it's interesting...
a lot of people find it easier to
learn a language using, say, literature
translated from their own language,
so Harry Potter for example, where
they're already familiar with the story.
I always start a new language doing
our mini stories at LingQ because
those are sort of familiar situations,
scenarios, things that people do in
any culture, meet with their friends,
eat food, clean up their room.
So these are also very familiar
situations, uh, and the more
familiar something is, the
more comfortable we feel.
I always like to develop a high
level of listening comprehension
and reading comprehension and, uh,
a significant level of vocabulary so
that I can understand what is said.
That, again, increases my comfort
level so that when I'm speaking with
people, at least I can, you know,
almost, or try to or feel that I can
understand much of what is being said
to me, even if I struggle to speak.
And of course, in struggling to
find words and in and worrying about
whether I use the correct, uh, you
know, structure that gives me a, a
sense of, you know, lack of comfort.
But if I have a comfort on the
comprehension side, I am again
carrying some of my sort of
comfort zone into my learning zone.
Uh, even in terms of the kinds of
learning activities that we do, we
should focus in on the situations
that we're more most comfortable.
So, uh, even in terms of reading,
of course I like to read on LingQ.
I like to look up words, but
there's also something comforting
about holding a paper book.
It's something that I've always done.
And so I typically, as I've
said, get a starter book for a
language that I'm starting into.
Uh, I like when I reach a level
where I can start to read and
there aren't too many new words.
I like to read books away from the
computer because again, I'm introducing
something that's comfortable to me,
something that I'm used to doing
that increases my comfort level
while I'm in the learning zone.
Um, some of my learning activities,
uh, for example, at LingQ, our
newsentence review function.
Uh, obviously if I'm focusing in
on, you know, a particular sentence
and using the matching pairs to go
over some of the vocabulary and then
reassembling the sentence at the end.
These are learning activities
that in a way slow me down because
I'm not acquiring new words.
But by the same token, there's
a sense of comfort in focusing
in on this level of detail.
And, and it's also an
activity which is pleasing.
So if you have a, an activity, a
learning activity that is pleasing,
that also introduces a level of comfort.
I was even thinking
that now with my Polish.
I'm gonna try writing.
You know, I'm reluctant to write in
languages where the writing system
is different because again, it's a
another level of stress trying to
write in this new writing system.
Other people may be more
comfortable doing that.
However, Polish is written in the Latin
alphabet, so as familiar and because
Polish has rather unique sort spelling
system where the SZ, CZ, and whatnot.
That, uh...
and write writing by hand is
something that's familiar to me,
and apparently writing by hand is
good for us in terms of learning.
So I'm gonna do some,
some writing by hand.
I even started doing that
when I do the sentence mode.
I then have the sentence which
I've reassembled, then I write
that sentence out by hand.
Again, a familiar activity that's
bringing some familiarity, some
comfort into my learning zone.
Uh, I think dealing with
content that's of interest.
So typically content that is of interest
is content that's familiar to us.
So again, when we have familiar, uh,
topics, which might be sports, if
we're into, into sports or anime or
anything that's familiar to us, that
increases the level of familiarity,
the comfort that we experience
while we're in that learning zone.
So, uh, just some things that I
was thinking that relate to this
issue of, of, uh, learning another
language, which ultimately is all about
getting outside of your comfort zone.
Uh, but there are things that we
can do to increase the level of
comfort in that learning zone.
Another one now that I think of it is, is
while I'm learning that language, I try
not to think of myself as a foreigner,
learning a strange language, but rather
as someone who wants to penetrate that
cultural environment and be like them.
So if I am like them, then I feel
more comfortable being with them,
and that again is an element of
comfort within the learning zone.
So I hope that was of interest to you.
It's something that came up,
uh, while I was, uh, doing
some research on the internet.
Uh, thank you for listening.
Bye for now.